the approval of a vaccine almost exactly
a year since covid19 first emerged in
wuhan china
is a triumph for science the final trial
data for the pfizer biontech vaccine
was only submitted to the uk regulator
the mhra a week ago
but as a result of a process of rolling
approval examining data
even as the trials were taking place the
regulator has been able to move swiftly
and
confidently to declare it effective and
safe the safety of the vaccine has been
scrutinized
independently by our commission on human
medicines
and no stone has been left unturned so
absolute confidence
in the safety effectiveness and quality
of the pfizer biontech vaccine britain
has bought 40 million doses of the fisa
biontech jab
and the first 800 000 doses will be
available in the uk
next week 10 million doses will be
delivered this year
and the remainder will arrive during
2021.
this is a monumental step forward
it's no longer if there's going to be a
vaccine it's when
in our battle against the virus help is
on its way
there are still challenges this specific
vaccine needs to be kept between
minus 70 celsius and minus 80 celsius
meaning that hospitals will almost
certainly have to be the main
hubs for distribution but it can be kept
for up to five days at
normal fridge temperature between two
degrees and eight degrees celsius
individuals need two jabs 21 days apart
for full protection and in the uk a
committee called the jcvi
says elderly care home residents and
their carers
will be first in line in order to
protect the most
vulnerable we have prioritized the most
vulnerable individuals first
the other element is protection of the
nhs the health and social care system
because by protecting the nhs we also
protect lives
the challenge now will be to manufacture
and distribute the quantities required
to meet what will inevitably be
extraordinary demand
britain has a head start but the united
states has ordered 100 million doses of
the pfizer biontech jab
and the european union 200 million
i hope they'll be rolled out everywhere
in the world as soon as possible because
we really need it what england does and
why i'm not sure i hope it comes to
italy soon
if they carried out the due tests and
their results are the real results and
not approximate ones then it's welcome
anyway the english are not stupid they
have a brain
there are several other vaccines
undergoing final stage trials
and vaccine candidates by modena and
oxford astrazeneca
have been submitted to regulators with
the uk's approval
pfizer biontech are leading the field
the options for tackling this global
pandemic
are likely to get even wider within a
matter of weeks
paul brennan al jazeera london